in the era of Trump there are more
moderate Republicans that seems sort of
like comparative voices of reason John
McCain Mitt Romney George W Bush and I'm
careful any time I say this not to
normalize those individuals the fact
that Bush finds some of trumps actions
wacky doesn't mean george w bush was a
good president doesn't meet doesn't mean
george w bush didn't do horrific things
we can now add Arnold Schwarzenegger to
the list Arnold has been hugely critical
of Trump in many areas and now he's
devoting a bunch of his free time to
gerrymandering he wants to terminate for
lack of a better term gerrymandering
we've talked about number one the
importance of gerrymandering in our
elections and we've also talked number
two about the fact that it's really
difficult to get people to care about
gerrymandering because it's kind of
wonky and boring and when it's when it's
December after a presidential election
it's hard to get the kids activated
around gerrymandering yeah it's not one
of those issues that are straightforward
- it requires a two minute explanation
before you completely understand it and
the Republican Party has done incredibly
well when it comes to redistricting
they've helped themselves at multiple
levels of government since 2008
Democrats have lost more than a thousand
legislative seats across the country
Democrats hold 39 fewer seats in the
house three fewer in the Senate 13 fewer
Democratic governors than in 2007 and
part of this has to do with urban-rural
divide as gerrymandering expert bill
Oglesby talked to us about a while ago
on the program but part of this does
have to do with the way that the
districts are drawn and instead of I
don't know showing up on a late-night
talk show to promote this project Arnold
has been drawing a huge audience with
these short funny videos including
quotes from his movies here's just one
okay and the idea is to explain these
important political issues I guess in a
way that will appeal to everybody some
of the things - the more popular than
congress hemroids nickelback traffic
jams cockroaches root canals
colonoscopies herpes even herpes they
couldn't beat herpes in the polls
gerrymandering has created an absurd
reality that politicians now picked up
voters instead of the voters picking the
politicians the hell video you thought
that every two years in November you're
going to the polls to pick your
representatives right wrong you called
Flat Earth bastard in California the
system was rigged so bad that between
2002 and 2010 we held 265 congressional
elections guess how many districts
changed party hands only one using
gerrymandering our politicians threw
their district lines so safely that even
though congressional approval ratings
when sometimes down into the single
digits
they couldn't lose couldn't have said it
better myself
so this is cool right he's got a on he's
using crowd PAC and online fundraising
platform to raise money to help a legal
challenge in Wisconsin to how districts
were drawn President Obama has talked
about getting involved trying to end
gerrymandering would be sort of
interesting to see Arnold and Obama sort
of like the new cross party political
duo kind of like the new George HW Bush
and Bill Clinton tour the country
promoting an end to gerrymandering it
doesn't make sense that Schwarzenegger
is picking this issue to champion though
because it's not too politically
divisive I mean you can get Democrats
and Republicans on board with it and
individual voters here actual Congress
people yeah not so much
yeah exactly when it comes to actually
lobbying Congress people it's a little
bit of a different thing but I support
this there was also a so now we're one
of the questions is if we eliminate
gerrymandering how should districts be
drawn and you can check out auto
district I'm sorry Auto redistricting
and it's a computer algorithm that can
create equal precincts based on
population and geographic data and
listen it doesn't have to be that but
we've got it the system we have is
clearly not working that's what we have
to get away from there's really no
perfect way to redistricting and of the
legislators themselves
anybody who an independent commission
what about a multi-part esand commission
would you be open to that I mean it's
better than what we have but I don't
love it I don't love it because you can
also have deal-making
if you've got a bipartisan redistricting
commission that has Democrats and
Republicans if you have more Republicans
in the legislature they can use their
strength in the legislature to
strong-arm the Democrats that are on the
redistricting committee right so I still
don't like it
usually these proposals can conclude
like include maybe one Republican one
Democrat in a whole bunch of yeah in the
middle who are bureaucratic
representative there enough maybe that's
the best approach
yeah there's listen what I can tell you
with certitude is almost any approach
would be better than the one we have we
have to think creatively to come up with
worse approaches not more effective ones